and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 33 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a Lord whose work
catalog I've been a tremendous fan of
for some time now this Lord initially
took the internet by storm and
galvanized most of martial arts in
gaming communities with his amazing
Taekwondo moveless from my personal
favorite Tekken character of all time
the kicking and flamingos feint machine
what I'm although this Lord is one of
the best martial artists in the business
he's extremely personable has a
hilarious sense of humor and his passion
for gaming is evident and everything he
does including his incredible men's
health training workouts introducing the
actor / stuntmen and creator of the
Tekken in real life series the Lord
responsible for the best portrayal of
striker in the Mortal Kombat Legacy
series and the creator of the legendary
action film the dictionary the real-life
local Jin himself MAME Lord Eric Jacobus
how are we doing sir good to get to have
have a huge fan of your work I don't
mean I've followed you for some time and
it's an absolute pleasure to have you on
the i lords podcast and we ready to get
this thing going minute okay I can't
wait nice absolutely and of course we
have the usual suspects at the round
table
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother and the how of the
young wolf mommy
Lord addict are we doing sir pretty good
just recovering from mentally from the
that cuphead stream I literally spent
like probably two and a half to three
hours on one boss and I had his I had
his entire pattern down had the whole
pattern down and I was just like I'm
done so I quit come back
and I beat not one not two but three
bosses in an hour and a half Wow
I'm hearing that company is beat the
infamous dragon boss on island 2 that
everyone's been saying stuff about yeah
man I gave that gays real difficult
really good good no doubt no doubt
and of course most technical Gaming Lord
the solo game who lives for the single
player selfish experience semi offline
xbox profile Illuminati moppet Lord
sovereign how are we doing sir a little
nasal today so I apologize for that in
advance
oh I have my sexy boys going today same
thing would come in order not to break
your controllers and the TV oh man it's
real it's real course the excess gamer
cool the lord of combat sports who was a
man of his convictions in demands
nothing less than the premium experience
Oh beloved Lord King how are we doing
sir
we're doing fantastic today um I don't
have much on combat sports to go on keep
your comments to yourself because our
guest today is about that life yes sir
but um combat sports this week is a
little down we had some fights last
night we had a little bit of UFC last
night no big cards we have big cards
coming on the 14th and the 13th coming
up but we did get a couple of insights
on Luis Ortiz Farrell and his drug test
so yeah Dianna think Beyonce while the
fight might be off but Deontay Wilder is
still pushing for the fight they just
get some compensation in the way of that
I don't know but I really was looking
forward to that fight
but guys here cuphead is real a carpet
is very real we're gonna get into that a
little bit later and of course we have
shadow five-o the jin kazama
demoralizing and the lord who would
check all fairway nonsense on his
Twitter feed the aggressively neutral
gamer love it
Lloyd Cobb Otsu how are we doing sir I
am doing great has a very productive
weekend and gaming I just be Cup hit
this morning because you know I am so
difficult the older games were harder if
you pay contra hardcore contra hardcores
is harder but what the game is just
astounding as a bloody mess you're
talking about a beautiful game that
would meticulously put together and the
way that the difficulty is set it set at
a nice difficulty it is not too hard if
you can't play old-style
twitch gaming stay away I hate that it's
a classic and it's good to see everybody
picking it up and supporting the game so
and of course it is located here
spreading their gaming realness on the
ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so before
we get into what the Lords of playing
this week I want to start with Lord
Eric's whose video game system history
including his love for fighting games
and the birth of Tekken is Chicago gin
also the Lords would like to know about
his martial arts background fighting
inspirations and of course the
incredible stunt work and film Chris
let's start first with the video game
system history lore Eric like what was
the first systems and got in games that
got you into this thing sorry I just my
cultist dropped and I just caught the
end of that question don't worry so much
we'll start from the beginning we
basically would start with you're in a
video game
in history like what was the first
gaming systems you have had I was born
82 so Miss B Atari just by a little bit
and when I was I think I think I mean it
turns before and my dad Kavya Wow think
you know my dad played a little bit of
arcade back in the day so he can
understood video games and you know when
he got it for me I was playing it all
day you know excited at the game that
came with it which is Mario and duck
hunting and playing classics he's kind
of fitting bad but yeah kids these days
they just want to play video games and
then I get up and you know three o'clock
in the morning of course and I sneak out
to the family room where with an is he I
see him punched over with the light gun
good yeah yeah playing he's like sitting
on the couch and buzz and then you know
I would spend my allowance and buy game
all the times is that for Nintendo and
then from there I acquired every
mainstream games with them and a lot of
strange ones in between from oh yes a
progression from me from the NES to what
was kind of like the next kind of couple
systems you remember I know I got the
Genesis after that a nice some reason I
was a Genesis kid and now I Bobby Lord
Eric baby so we appreciate you saying so
now i think i think the sega system was
much more the arcade system and this
super nintendo would be the RPG system
yeah I think like the brainy kids that
super nes but those of us there are fast
twitch and wanted to just get down and
dirty really quickly did you what was
some of those early games for Genesis
the moment of standouts for you what it
was like to mortal kombat one one with
the blood baby
that's right
dice that's know was a huge one and oh
man i splatterhouse to was my other one
oh yes there we go I actually got a
little bit of history with me right here
I'm calling out oh well now here we go
there we go I think that excludes one
eye Lord from mother I don't have many
of these anymore but I did keep this one
Wow Wow oh no hang on that's a classic
you've got a hankie community was
amazing for its time this world I think
I was working out first that was made by
one guy one guy made out of this world
air time
yes remember that one this game right
here you let me tell you right now you
you plug in heartstrings because I'll
just world that game they just released
it again four feet deep yes and I
believe Xbox Xbox Live and they also put
it back out and that game to me was so
amazing for its time you know they even
when you start and you've beat the alien
is like max or video game system history
is pretty epic that is very cool so um
what about F as far as now I know you
said one comment so what about like
transitioning that into what people most
know you for obviously is your tech and
move list so tell me about from the
fighting game aspects how can your love
of a fighting games like how did that
progress which games which fighting
games yeah we also a bunch of us we're a
bunch of sad or a bunch of Sega kids
though we buzzing 32x I have a Sega CD I
got one thing to ask in regard
that's one thing I didn't even know he
had to say g'sten ask him does he have
eternal champions for the Sega CD one of
the best fighting games out there I mean
I've loved that one
that's called it Sophie I know you still
got Sophie I got somewhere I had so many
games I'd love to have like 3,000 games
at one point you you are definitely
strikes being earned right now a lot of
respect a lot of salute we've been into
me here at the round table so anyway
back to you know fighting games a lot of
us were Saturn kids they good kids
we were retired kids and the local
arcade carries Virtua Fighter and loves
my mother chill fighter but I'm sorry
when Tekken came out / - sure has it
took such a backseat for that game man
just Tekken really really - took the
crown yeah characters that were pretty
unique absolutely absolutely I mean the
thing about - was just how the realism
right and how it portrayed martial arts
I felt it more than any other game
Virtua Fighter kind of caught up later
on but took a while what really
separated it was the fact that you had
you know left punch Right punch left
kick right simple to everybody and it
was easy to get your head around the
fact that but instead of just punch kick
block you know like punch big block is
so ambiguous you know but left punch
Right punch the way you screen punches
together um listen I'm a combat fan
lover love them all right we like I need
to be Carl or cog needles and I tell you
we have this thing called channel 5 the
reason why we're called channel 5 is
because every Saturday we you know
we'll get the old John wolf wolf films
master mall films and yeah yes yes and
we would do you know I don't know from 3
o'clock to 12 o'clock midnight we go get
a three karate films and we watch it we
all chip in we pick it up we sit there
we watch it until we found out something
that went down and there but with it but
uh yeah we are astute fans of old
fighting history so I'm so happy to have
you here today
trust me when I saw that you were coming
on I was I was happy basically what King
was also implying was that Oh we'll get
back to his one point that he was
implying in reference to when we seen
the martial arts represented these guys
kicked you know I was a huge John Liu
fan right and yeah I go back right so
that was my guy and I remember that you
know movies like the secret rivals you
know all these guys these great kickers
when Jenny Lee and we would just saw a
were God's to us right at that age so
when we saw like finally we as you get
older and your eyes get a little better
and you start to realize that not only
these guys are great but it's the only
thing you realize like wait a minute
they did the back flip did the triple
tuck and all that stuff that was it them
some weight and they lost some height
and we were so free for our own guys
like our whole guys we were like now my
guy doesn't do that he does all
so explain to us what Eric about that
just real quickly about there like that
the stunt culture in those like 70s
karate saw slash Constance licks oh
sorry I mean you're talking about John
Liu John Liu is uh he's kind of a
prodigy out of he was born in Japan
actually I was just researching him he's
actually Japanese born and you know he
was coming up in a time when kicking was
really taken off and I've been doing a
lot of Reena stopping and looking up
what kicking in film looked like before
Bruce Lee because there was none
Wow wasn't much looked a lot and there
was nothing going on and you know the
culture at the time he really
popularized it because it was
interactive with Chuck Norris and a lot
of what he's yes America Chuck Norris
came back from from Korea cuz he picked
up tongue sudo in Korea he brought
kickboxing back to America made that
really popular in the karate circuit and
we met Bruce Lee that oh why don't I
kick above the bed Bruce Lee picked it
up within two years and goes I'm
training together at one and and the
next thing you know and he's in 1971 the
big boss comes out and they kickin
culture suddenly just explodes kicking
kicking ass yes because really
marketable and like nothing really beat
kicking out until in the making around
so people still are doing kick kick just
don't kind of the hot thing and tricking
and all that think of it 35 years worth
of that kind of legacy John Liu really
kind of carried the sport in the late
70s he was panting with you know Hong
Kong Korea Taiwan a little bit of Japan
and and he was the the right lake master
yes
absolutely absolutely thanks for a
decade that's where that was definitely
an idol of mine and definitely cool to
talk about so let's get back to you how
to read a little off track but uh what
did it go so personally like you're as
far as on your martial arts background
like what what are the arts that you
specifically specializes and also like
some personal fighting inspirations as
well
I I started martial art pretty late in
life I was about twenty actually someone
I really loved it because I wanted to do
stunts I want to create bike news and
I've done a little bit it was more of a
weightlifter my boy years and the
college and then when I moved to the Bay
Area to go to film school I said I
really gotta get the martial arts
because my home town reading Northern
California they didn't really have a
whole lot in in terms of martial arts I
kind of max a lot of that out one of my
martial arts schools close down and lock
the door on me when I came in hola bad
experiences so I open up those phone
book when I moved in terms ago and I
went down the list and the second one I
found was like one dose cool mmm
so I started doing that my future was
Andy Leone and I've been contour as the
the at the co-star and I did a bunch of
movies with him two years later I met
Dennis rule and Ray Carbonell and they
taught me how to you know and I've been
doing that oh wow that is amazing
that is pretty amazing and Hapkido by
the way just a quick a quick quick
little lesson on that Hapkido was really
be taking art of the feminism mm-hmm
great if you trace any of the Hong Kong
stunt guys back it really goes back to
and Bruce Lee brought Jeon J and you
know bong soo hyung was kind of the the
American guy but in Hong Kong it Deonte
and one in six and he was the young
master and Dragon Lord and Sam aha
but all of his buddies all of his
brothers I get and view they all went to
a speedo hmm guy named Kim Jim Powell
and they learned have pedo their kicks
are very happy though and oh they do
have I love I love dock window I'm very
proud to kind of carry in the Gita
lineage nice I mean it's pretty amazing
what you do so transitioning that into
like the whole tech in move lists in in
how that whole transfer
because that's what kind of me let you
broke the internet when those things I
remember seeing I'm like who is this guy
so tell me like what was the idea behind
that and getting that started I think
you know the dictionary was where it
started and that was you know I saw this
video where a guy puts together I think
it was maybe 50 judo move he did
something similar where he just put the
name at the bottom and they just went
through 50 judo moves in 30 seconds
there's nothing like that
you know surprises nobody had done that
was kicks the only person who had ever
really done it was funk Guns II there
was a thing that he did you know
feature-length film where he just goes
through every kick and how to do them
all the like basic eight back window
kicks in every variation of those kick
gotcha right nobody had ever done
something like that again with all the
updates there's so many to kick that
have come out then that people have
innovated upon one generally he's
kicking because he was really the master
and very gianlu but Lord Craig was he
was a Wang Jing Li we have sex be called
master boy arrivals you know when they
stopped that in Korea and the Vietnam
War and ended knows 1976 in each other
we were rivals I think or 75 in one gun
he was in the Korean War man I got the
fat ass
and it was hired that guy they knew that
they had everybody in that movie yes yes
I think a lot of us were inspired by
that guy so the canary was a little bit
of a him although it was much more like
last year right I wasn't gonna do it
with a karate Horan doing it and then
from that you know because I found a lot
of the kicks in video games so I was
taking this from anywhere I can so it's
really trying to get 230 points and that
sounds you know a big fight or maybe a
couple packing
so release the kicked an area that did
really well and then I was looking at
doing a second one nose in China him
working out at home called heart of a
champion and I started as putting
together a second kickin dictionary when
I was at a gym I'm just working on it
every day and trying to make a couple
new kicks trying to just start looking
at second I just started watching every
second room mmm entire removalist then
has anybody ever done and I looked at
online and nobody had done it and I
thought you know this is a weird idea
but since nobody's done it seems gonna
hop suddenly and when I came home from
China went to garage and it just been
hours and days and days in the garage
working on long and lay you long and
[Laughter]
nothing is done like I don't want to
call it a higher calling but that's what
it seemed like you know I definitely
then when I did it like wow that took
off real quick I went from 20,000
subscribers to 80,000 pretty quick
minute sir good for you absolutely it's
great I mean we saw it was amazing now I
know lord carboxy had a question what
query Crescent is first of all to you
how you got how you did the move this
was really cool and then even when you
had the the animations for the you know
like high middle low as far as the
detective but you always have the edge
because he always told you a little bit
of humor in these movements so Laura
Watson wants to know about the first
couple ones I don't have a cat in there
and I think like its way along I've come
in and so just I was just doing it when
I was working on the garage one of our
cats walk in the middle of the shots
what are you doing and then finally I
just kind of play around with one I did
some moves on the cat and I threw it in
there and then then when you put a cat
in the video break the Internet you
always have to have the cat doing some
God body stuff then everyone you know
the commenters are great they would
always love academy think he's been
there and so I started up the world
every time and it's like the open that
really because the commenters responded
so well to the cat that I started kind
of coming up with in jokes with them and
that's how the cat came around humid
definitely shows her that it's pretty
amazing also we want to talk about like
what you're up your stunt work I know
you said like you started also with that
and then you got a martial arts late but
um you know you got into the kind of
collective bug for the stunt craze and I
also want to talk about you know your
indie film career and all things that
you got not jumping off to so let's
start off with it with the stunt work
what got you into that like what
possessed you to do that a lot of when I
was a kid
Charlie Chaplin and I'm like now yeah I
like how these guys really used their
body of authority and you need Jackie
Chan is gonna take that take inspiration
from that when he made martial art
movies which is really kind of crazy
because everyone was trying to make him
into the next Berkeley and it wasn't
really happening and I think that Jackie
being where he came from you know he's
an only child somewhat somewhat of an
only child didn't really come from a
place to Thanks I think the way that
Bruce Lee did you know growing up in in
Seattle and different let's go I think
you know Jackie Chan was a very
different kind of person than Bruce Lee
was yeah that's why he you flocked to
the physical comedy and there there are
just certain kinds of people that are
really into that and then there's
certain kinds of people who are the
quickly type in the demo Hong type yes
the people that want to win fight with
technicality
people that want to win fights with some
kind of gag or some kind of sometimes
even just like a smart witty element and
that was the Jackie Chan saying when I
saw Jackie Chan and I saw him late in
life because again we just didn't really
have much going on in my home town Romel
the Bronx with the first Jackie Chan
movie I saw mm-hmm and I got kind of
addicted to him and Memphis you know
even before the internet I managed to
find all this movie no no but you know
managed to find talking about new at one
point and that's when I knew I really
really want to do something like this
because he's using his body not just not
just comedic Lee but he's just doing
interesting cool stuff it's really fast
and the tactic and confusing and really
wanted to do that and so I just a nice
I'm just gonna do it because at some
point I was reviewing movies for a while
too because I had a website review Hong
Kong movies and I'll just review the
action would review the story or
anything I reviewed 500 movie and I
think I understood that right thing and
so we just went out and various people's
like we did it every week in 2001 we
shot the movie every weekend we had like
35 short film at the end of 2001 like 19
how we called some people and we would
make all the time and I was a tech kid
so I could edit the movie but I also
wanted to perform I would get a camera
guy I would be camera guy that use the
camera guy would do everything we wear
every hat nice man that's pretty cool
and then yeah we I wasn't getting
mysterious about it for a long time
because I was you know I was in the Bay
Area so I didn't really get heavily
involved in like the Hollywood scene
until 2012 or so and at the end of me
was at the end of 2012 that I got called
Mortal Kombat like mmm that's when you
did that the legendary striker role yeah
also you're one of your idols is on that
uh mister mister Dacascos nice the rest
of the iron Lords are lord cardbox who
are lost soft that's uh what's that
movie I'm only too strong but the pan
that's a classy well - cuckoos I was how
was it like on set with him like would
you get a chance to interact with a
month yeah I got to hang out we actually
we were fighting together but it have
been amazing he was gonna come on that
right
nice nice we we just we did some long
nights and I was having some like
relationship issues with with a old
girlfriend at the time and you know
standing there late at night tired I was
kind of looking out looking at the ocean
moldings and he comes up he says hair
how's it going man I was like kind of
like having a girl cool man just keep
putting that energy out there it'll come
right back people feel really good you
know he was he was he was always
complimentary you know he go at all mmm
that's very cool he always seems to
given off positive energy I always get
that vibe from him you know yours it
spice foot that's cool eh absolutely so
well any any as far as well as far as
film is concerned like any other things
we got working on to plug on the IRP
okay nice nice I like where we're going
with this I'm I'm liking this the first
one takes place in a small amount of
time during the day and then part two
takes place in the second half of the
day okay okay cool looking at well we
should we be on the lookout for that one
coming soon before the end of the
because all right because we're
being down we just gotta do some final
touches on post-production on yeah
minimize hopefully before the end of
here but no doubt and the last question
I had for you as far as ohm dad is
concerned also want to know what what do
we have to do get Hirata's on to get
either his own character like he was
expressed interest of course they're not
working on second eight probably anytime
soon but there's gonna be pushing Tekken
7 for a while and whatever other schemes
they're doing it being a Namco but I
have no idea how to crack that nut
seriously okay
the Lord our Lord is gonna work the back
Santos this has to happen or something
fall with it the rest of the Lords are
have any other questions for Lord Eric
so I get into the question of course my
question is at this point I'm because
we're growing up we had so many martial
artists to choose from like we will
literally be inside a room full of guys
and everybody could pick one guy like
that's my guy and I don't think the kids
growing up today or the guys growing up
today have that that guy we need a
resurgence in that market like to that
that push that the the old Shah brother
films I mean I we saw it with whether
the iron fist this guy and I thought it
was gonna go back to that do you have
any insight on any new push from
Japanese or Korean actually really
Korean of films being trying to
push this back into the American culture
mmm well I mean you still do have you
still have a little bit of that in
America I think MMA has really what
would you say I guess in amazement of de
guerre or innocence it's like when we
now they they all know that you know the
second you throw a backflip with a kick
they go well you can't really do that
the ring but that's cool you know I look
that would be so cool to do that and we
kind of suspended disbelief more easily
back then with action films it seems
very difficult to do that now it's like
it's hard to blend the the real with I
don't know not supernatural but with the
with the flashing you know what I mean
yeah that's a good point I think also
back then there was justice in the 80s
there was still a sense of wonder yeah
discover new things in the eighties
can't find anything new now if you think
about it which is a little bit
depressing you can't really find a you
know every there's no such thing as like
the Northey untii the the Buried North
Korean cinema history right we I mean
even you can even get North Korean films
you can get them all and I know that
like when all of us were growing up we
find the new movie from Taiwan that was
30 years old or something and we like
yeah nobody had seen it and we managed
to bite it you know and our buddies say
yeah buddy doesn't won't be age and
that's gone I don't think that those
times are coming back because we're
completely global well I don't I don't
like the fact that we remake everything
we don't remakes classic sha brother
films I know I know I mean we're talking
about remaking the rain and stuff like
that but we're yeah you don't want to I
mean even though I know what you mean
with man with the iron fist but that was
really kind of a comic book movie in a
way it wasn't
they're too much fun yeah I know
so yeah it's yeah I think it is that
it's that combination of anime where
everything gonna have to be grounded and
summative real yeah got real or you have
to do a superhero it's like finding a
middle ground now I'm not sure anybody's
really willing to take of it gosh is
just what I wear I do see it a lot is in
the indie martial arts game which is
still kind of small but a lot of us that
sort of came up watching these movies we
make our own films but very difficult to
go mainstream with any martial art film
because the market they all demand MMA
or you know Kasich appoint you know and
in that sort of the situation we're in
right now
gotcha gotcha yeah that's actually a
very very good point but I know I know
one thing I mean at least with the
fighting game aspect you know you know
mocap and all these things you know
these guys I mean when I was looking at
your history and I was actually
surprised when you actually mentioned
that a Harada a lot of these animations
they weren't all done by mocap like they
was some of them were actually you know
generated and stuff like that that
actually surprised me like oh how did
you feel when you when you heard about
that when you actually replicating all
these technique actor Muslims it's
actually amazing what they can pull off
with hand animation an interviewer even
said that the first Tekken was entirely
hand animation which we want the first
technique actually looks like looks like
motion capture maybe and then there are
something but I don't know but it's
amazing that they can though but it's I
know I knew that the combos were not
motion capture because the emotion comes
to me in difficult lose string them
together because no capping the combo
and kind of a question but a little bit
of a shock finding out that
we put the hunting controversy to rest
Oh Lord Eric cuz people act like this is
a move that could really be done by they
accuse you of educate these guys no it's
not humanly possible Tosa if you could
do that back toe side cut they thought
he challenges yes this man is going to
be it SID one day cause like you told me
to your favorite Tekken character
character or characters be broken right
now
hmm what Stan says you did that Phoenix
tears with crane but the stairs was the
flows talk to me I would go yeah so do
man I'm Sabrina second no I was like tag
the tag with your submit to and play
along and I would do ya later long I
know into that that the the the I do the
down back left kick okay between snake
that would bring me in the snake and I
do like there are three right punches
the snake on the ground
lol are
okay that way oh no no you were very
good are you talking to real technical
talk now what's interesting is that what
blew you up was not necessarily late so
it was wrong so which was my favorite
character so tell me like like how did
that it was just because you didn't see
anyone doing his move list or just his
movements was just more flashy appealing
he felt it to represent the reason I
started actually that was the first one
that I did was and I was beginning I got
that picking trees targeting that I had
in those videos no I bought that for
training and you know it just seemed
like the perfect thing to do a [ __ ] on
and yes so I and I'm very happy that she
did I was happy with the reader i
retweeted your remake up the Tekken 7
because I actually I was appreciative
because I'm a fan of flamingo stance and
you had it it was it for this hood and I
was like yes he's got let me go I'm good
I'm satisfied cool cool question by the
Lord before we get into the show some
things also I have to commend you
specifically on the Bob move list
ever since Bob debuted I was like there
is no way anybody can actually fight
like this I'm like if you're a fat guy
the most you're gonna fight like is like
Sammo hung but the actual movement with
the flips with the rolls and all that
and actually making it looking high I
was like oh my god insane so I got to
commend you for that you got to put that
out it's hilarious the question I really
wanted to bring up to you as since
you're like a heavy martial artist
and as people who've been playing the
Tekken series you've noticed that the
Tekken series over the years the styles
have gotten a little bit more extreme
and non-believable and we kind of come
to the point is like what other styles
could they actually put in Tekken the
only one I have on my mind currently
right now is monkey-style but other than
that I'm out of ideas like what do you
think
with your experience interestingly they
put out this Josie character Filipina
character but she just ruthless and put
it there
it's kind of surprising like you would
think that they would put like me I mean
I know that it's not really kosher to
put weapons into seconds but you can do
some kind of Kali as grandma that's
empty-handed you know - yeah I mean that
would be kind of cool I think it's
pretty obvious now that Wing Chun is
making a big comeback because of it
ma'am yeah did something like that I
don't know how they don't know how you
would but I'm sure that you could take
the apeman move list now I'm making them
do a character it's gonna now be very
calm - happy yeah exactly yeah just like
the rapid punches I mean I think that'd
be pretty hard but did that I think
maybe I don't know you just do yeah
really it does Nina but hey but can you
imagine how frustrating that would be
it's funny you say that because that's
why I gravitated towards a Craig Marek
because I thought they were gonna try to
attempt that you know fully with him
with a mount stance and stuff like that
Lord addict you have something you want
to say about Jitsu I'm all for making a
character that annoys people like I
don't play ahead to have fighters but I
know people get upset with like grabs on
their dead fighters imagine like a
character that only does that that's
well how I'm a that's how I played Craig
Marek
[Music]
Lord Kylie don't pay people afraid to
get on the ground
King master house Craig Craig Monica nan
actually when he's tiger that's a good
segue Eddy Gordo's moveless we have it
see I'm hoping I don't see any comment
related to he physically do anymore do
not do old man oh no what he could do is
he could get a co-host and you know if
they could have a second Mark Dacascos
[Music]
[Laughter]
movie I've ever seen represent that art
I mean it correct me if I'm wrong
America I don't remember films I mean
kind of big guy who represent capoeira
right now out there on the market you
know he was the guy in the protector
with Tony Jaa
yes y'all made Eddie Gordo in the
terrible terrible Tekken movie I came on
a blog sorry satisfied I hated all read
the word
[Laughter]
because the company don't the the live
action right the second they have to
make a movie every five years less lion
20 I think that 2014 you did that's
terrible second they're like we're gonna
make it as lease we're gonna spend as
lease money as possible make this
knowing it's terrible just to keep these
rights Fox bastardizing my Fantastic
Four series so we gonna get in real
quick
home what the Lord's been playing this
week so let's start with a lot of Eric I
know you've been busy was the last kind
of game that you you know you don't get
an ending the guys that did the The
Monkey Island game yeah yeah we park and
it was kick-started kind of in the style
of maniac mansion and yeah wrong ever
nice I played a lot of Tekken 7 lately
cuz I got a ps4 I think I Tekken if we
got to play that tag so are we are we
competitive with the Tekken one of the
top guys no joke
I think my my username is double on PSP
PlayStation Network go and add me and I
got you big challenge you be prepared to
win I'll bring my what I got now I'll
stunt like I'm the realtor you know what
Cognito is doing right now don't you
he's on the Amazon that's why another
place they shouldn't put this on you I
gotta take my videos get over to Lord
adequate what have you been playing this
week okay investing you know I could
kind of see why you know we're gonna
talk about it we're gonna give him today
that's what about time as we get into it
have you been playing this week I'm up
and playing some destiny getting getting
my power level up so I'm at 290 finally
so I'm ready for this latest nightfall
and then Wow are you guys to help me out
with this request I've been playing I've
been playing some fantastic it's it's
difficult but it's fair and that's
that's a that's a that's that balance
it's tough destructive those type of
games fair but it's firm if you die is
your low though and besides that the
switch mess which has 18 games come out
this past weeks it literally 18 games
that a lot of them are aware but then
you have some good well just a lot of
them was trouble with it was your well
we
here we go kids
racism again you know I am if it wasn't
for Lord King I'd have to deal with this
so it's price every minute and I'm going
to show you you should have started you
should like are you interested in the
Nintendo switch in any capacity have you
seen it or this is something that
doesn't know it seems cool because you
got like those good little switches and
you can use your hands and move me that
seems cool but I mean if it goes like
wheeze they're gonna be you know five
four titles and then 150 that was mo
you're definitely definitely that
there's there's some arguments towards
this trip as far as the the shovelware
titles and stuff like that but there's
also some some great quality tiles the
Lords of planes and I was in Lord NORs
off as far as kool Moe King what are you
complain sweet Oh destiny I finished the
raid twice and did the prestige
nightfall and a regular nightfall I'm
working on my third character now which
will be a hunter because I found out
this infinite super that you can do with
this new exact Supes
so definitely a train on my character
that way then I'm gonna delete one of my
warlocks to make a Titan you know start
him from the ground up so I can have all
three represented but new monarchy
that's one of my factions dead orbit is
one of my factions and I'm getting this
third character up so I can put them in
what is it you want you all call yeah
and playing carpet
started cuphead yesterday officially I
you know the first night I touched it I
wanted to see because I couldn't believe
it was real you know honestly I had to
see it on my television then I tweeted
that out that it was in my television
and I tweeted that Phil you know please
get more promotional in this game
because it's an xbox exclusive and I
really want the world to know about this
game it's 20 bucks so I think let me
tell you what it's vanity right it's
right up your alley - its class like 19
but would you say that is it's like the
admire both of the guys that worked on
the game didn't they like lose their
jobs we're gonna give me the card
oh you will and so on it's also is it
part of the Windows 10 stores if yes
right now for my PC because I purchased
it on my xbox and the cool thing about
Xbox is a lot of big exclusive titles
when you purchase it on your digital for
your system you can play it anywhere on
any Windows PC just downloaded it but um
I really want this game to be push more
because for 20 bucks if you own an Xbox
and you're no that's my selfless Pro
promo for the game because everybody in
the chat should have it so that's that
set me going to the Lord Kaiba - what
have you been playing I'm assuming come
in also the usual destiny was able to
get the faction rallies get that going
on you know a lot a war you know how I
roll
this is probably nobody else besides me
and Brian will try to be saying it I was
playing my switch my lunch right now I'm
filling this the steamworld dig - that
isn't out stairs basically
you say what was the name of that game
team world what said said what again
world dig - Oh steam a bit I think you
said something else there's a lotta
stuff coming to steam - I will see you
playing it so here's my argument for you
point out there the thing is the secret
to is an indie game that I would love to
play but the thing is on the Xbox you
can get it on the PlayStation 4 but the
thing is if I'm gonna put both seem
world dick 2 versus destiny - what am I
gonna play that is where the switch
finds the happy medium to play hosebag
because it's horrible and you're on the
go and especially like a guy like Eric
he's making movies he's on the go some
time to be at home in front of his big
ps4 on the big TV which you could fit in
those and that's the funny thing is
that's the argument that we all have
even King even I'm just telling you
here's my issue
nothing look I bought this for first
party ok and like like people become an
ad me where I might do like until Mario
Odyssey until like rabbits come out I
got nothing to play you got plenty to
play I'm like maybe you do but with a
less fair a lot of people were not
thought we're not playing the Wii U
games like every single Wii U release on
this which I'm like I never played this
oh this is the joint is hot I wasn't
we got lost let's get this go you still
go as far as our meet its being home as
far as on the Xbox is gonna destiny to
playing ton of it getting ready done
doing all that stuff arm as far as the
switch it's the NBA 2k 18 oh my gosh
I've been playing that to death just
love it and I played cuphead finally
last night I had a couple hours
I was thought to say I said cop head is
imperfect switch more like it just but
the thing about the game we're gonna get
into a lore addict stop talking about it
but that's pretty much what I've been
playing so let's get on with the shot
and we've been talking a little bit so
um we had last week's poll and that was
um the results are in the people have
spoken
so to the question when Deb's like
bethesda with doom square with Final
Fantasy 15 and take 2 with NBA 2k 18
attempt triple a switch ports does lower
resolution and frames per second
discouraging from buying in a razor
close poll the winner at 58% is the no
we want more fillet gaze or the switch
group so the people want they definitely
still want the triple A's and I'm in a
close second no close very close to 42%
was the yes we hate gilt triple-a
experience good thanks to all who
participated in last week's poll and
real quickly so we can move on what are
the launchers think about this when you
make the argument about about gimping
stuff on the swift you gotta remember
that as console gamers a lot of people
who are like PC elitist think that we're
playing to get version to the game so
it's everything is relative so you've
got to realize about the portability
because of the portability you can
really get the most out of those games
when you don't have the time to sit down
all over there so and plus to put that
little persistence like that portable I
would I would give you that argument if
this was solely you know marketed is
just affordable device but it's not is
it's marketed as also as a consular vice
yeah
let's be real if it wasn't portable it
would be we all over that makes it a
market in that way
you should have market as a portable you
can't market it one way and then not
take the negative publicity the other
way it just doesn't work like that
yeah but the sales are because of the
portable don't because you can't say
that you can't speak moving on so let's
get it to the round table all right
Lord King yes you had a topic talk about
it okay so um we all you know come from
some form of video game fighting
background I mean if you are playing in
the coin ops back in the days you know
you come in you plunk down your quarter
like we talked last week and you got
your fight on but we've seen the
evolution of video game fighting from
its inception you used to be the
one-on-one karate champ and now we've
worked our way and remember the karate
champ was crazy you get that one punch
victory now we worked our way up to
where we had Tekken 7 right now and um
more Marvel vs. Capcom you know infinite
games like that but what I've noticed
and we saw Tekken ii change certain
things in it like left punch Right punch
left kick right kick and that changed
the genre into another direction but
what also Tekken did was it had its
story now I went to got the story you
wanted to end the game with every last
character to get every last story
element with and uh what we see now is
microtransactions and downloadable
content downloadable characters to keep
the longevity into the fighting genre so
this past week of the week before this I
kept my segments for this I knew it was
fighting week
this is fighting so this is fighting
weekend um I brought Marvel vs. Capcom
infinite story
fantastic they didn't allow me to
broadcast the game for the first two
days I guess it had a little lock on it
or put a video up above the game there
the embargo was on it I guess but even
though the game was released didn't make
any sense it has a very rich story and
then you have the DLC with the
characters and the evolution of the
video game fighting what I wanted to
know what would you guys is where do you
see the future going in with this
because we have what is it um injustice
God among us with the deals and yes the
microtransactions with the great story
what is the next evolution in our fight
in genre that can keep this dying breed
alive because we only have a couple of
games fighting games right now as before
we used to have a huge variety you know
so great great topic let's let's get a
little more Erica non us to uh get his
assessment what would you like to see it
go I mean I would still like to see
something that much more flow based you
guys remember right most called rise the
honor that Jet Li game yes analog yeah
yeah it was kind of it didn't really
work but you kind of see whatever it was
just very like flow based fighting
system and I would love to see something
like that I have no idea how you do it
though mmm something more into it is you
know cuz I think Tekken sort of took it
to that next level with the left punch
Right punch left kick right right me and
by the way he's a little bit here's a
pop quick a trivia quiz the question
real quick what was the game did the
left punch Right punch left kick right
kick before Tekken
wow you may have got all optica no I
don't think was Thomas toboe came after
Tekken I thought after tagging it would
and the fighters didn't have that
because they just kind of block what
dude whoa yeah you got me stumped their
logo there was an arcade game called
time killer oh my
I didn't realize that there's a head
button and and you can do a one hit kill
if you knew if you do not time killers
have the worst fatalities ever I
remember that game remember yeah anyway
that's a great question so yeah that's
where I was like you go I want I'm
interested to see how VR is gonna shape
mining in definitely definitely have
like you know Tekken 7 has a VR did you
do you attempt to check it out I don't
have a VR kit
I don't have that goggle or yet I want
to get in like but not like it's
first-person of it or is it just looking
at seesaw like you were like at the side
of the fight that's what a foreign I
kept hearing about that I was not buying
Tekken for PlayStation I was waiting for
it on my eggs VR guys I'm surprised you
didn't get to be the VR is okay I don't
I'm not for the gimmicks like if you're
gonna actually you know make a VR game
then make a VR game like certain games
actually work in VR and right now to
this day Resident Evil 7 is probably the
scariest game going because of that BR
so alright so uh any laws us talk about
to about the what about how you feel
about the evolution of a fighting games
or maybe what he wants to see it go as
well as launchings points far as
microtransactions entering in well
microtransactions I can see
microtransactions in terms of like for
example with to--we're Tekken and
injustice you have so many costumes that
you that you can get with the characters
and also in justice even though it does
seem shady I do like the fact that
they'll give you a skin that's an
entirely different character with with
their own different dialogue and so if
that adds a little flavor weight and
that would actually pay extra for that
slow down loads but in terms of the
actual genre
it really hasn't gotten that different
over all over the years pretty much the
each one has their own their own
clothing system so I think more it would
be that to expand the the fighting game
genre you would need to go into
different ideas and I know I'm going to
get flack on this but it comes arms I'm
nice that actually has been a good
renovation because the thing I like arms
on they need to have a lot more that
package fighting itself in terms of the
fighting itself is not just mashing out
combos they actually do have combos if
you look into it but it's more you have
to attack you have to use the right type
of punch for the right situation also
you're waiting for your opponent and
since you're stretching your arms
there's a lot more like you have to do a
lot more movement to get away with it
it's more about the using the specific
moves rather than just go banging out
along combo okay I said I mean you know
and the thing is you know us guys we
play Tekken we play Tekken more than
Street Fighter and those other games why
because the thing is Tekken is has been
more towards using the right move for
the right situation rather than banging
out the combos as we know we're taking
there's gone with the juggles and I'm
glad that they toned it down for Tekken
7 yeah it got more back to the stand-up
fighting as opposed to so much okaz on
me so much combo lean that kind of stuff
so which is cool
Lord told us Lord sovereign what do you
feel about the evolution of fighting
games
Michael transactions and things
microtransaction stuff I think it's as
long as the base game that you're
getting is is fairly feature complete
and has a robust amount of stuff in it I
think it's fine I think
Street Fighter 5 made that mistake where
they gave you a very bare-bones game and
then sort of piecemeal everything off
after that and I think apart from the
heart or everybody sort of fell off of
the game quickly because of that because
there wasn't just enough meat there
initially so I think the micro time
accidents have to be relegated to like
you know like costumes and stuff like
that like look I bots who said and and
characters down the line that make sense
to pay more for characters down the line
but I think the basic eight has to be
pretty feature complete over for people
to stick to it initially fairly and it
and in terms of the UH the evolution of
the genre I think I think they've taken
in so many different directions I come
back to said with with the arms and
stuff like that
so I think people approaching fighting
games from different perspectives is
there and that will continue to happen
I agree with Lord arrogant in terms of
the flow style gameplay I want to see
them incorporating people being able to
really let loose with these different
styles and games and I know it's
difficult because you have to worry
about you know frames and hit boxes and
stuff like that so although this stuff
has to be incorporated so it's difficult
to make something that flows really
smoothly but I think that's that's
definitely the future um one thing that
I haven't seen a lot of lately which I
loved
is like injuries making during the
course of a fight you have to fight like
if you look back at Bushido blade and
something like that where you could die
you know but you could be injured also
you could be you could you could be hurt
and your gimped and then that limits the
moves that you can do during the course
of a match I think the UFC games have
started this sort of touch on that
obviously would like the progression of
injuries and how hurt you are during the
course of the game and stuff like that
but I think that real adding that
realism to a section of fighting games
would be very cool because we don't see
enough of that sort of stuff I want to
be able to be hurt in a match and then
have to change how I have to fight in
order to basically adjust like I like
the course of a real fight that's all
the stuff so hopefully somebody does
that sort of stuff nice Lord addict we
know you are not the head-to-head
fighting young boss but I'm curious on
your perspective on our fighters and the
what what what could they do to get you
kind of involved in fighting AIDS mmm
go back in time and make me play than
when I was a kid I don't know why
you know I understand that that concept
by it had fighters but like the way I
said I didn't have I didn't have people
to play that kind of that genre with so
I think our what people playing that
genre so I didn't continue playing that
genre I mean trust me people I've tried
to get me to play that genre and it's
just like no you're making a very valid
point I mean the fighting game culture
you definitely need someone who can
consistently get in in I mean you know
Walker box or knows like you know our
battles were legendary in Tekken and
lock in ghosts are still steel shop and
steel we push each other you know you
come back you get beat by your boy you
come back you try to work on your game
what did you do wrong what could you do
to combat certain moves so I hear what
you're saying but I guess would you Lord
addict another question real quick was
on as far I know you're a big you
actually you know trains widgets you
actually you know did some more MMA
so my question like what are the UFC
games didn't really appeal to you
neither you didn't try it was a cool
thing but you know as far as you know
playing them consistently I didn't
really do that either it's just like
it's different playing a video game and
actually you know like you know working
out and you know training itself it's
completely different like you can't
really transition from one to the other
like it gets the same filling and you
know I didn't do this very long like you
know I'm definitely not on like you know
by eighty means whatsoever level just
something I did on this side you know it
was mainly a thing that I did to stay in
shape back when I was in my early 20s
you know I'm still 25 so I'm still
technically I guess what would be an
injury a head-to-head fighter well I
don't think there's a while back there
was a game called rising thunder that
had see that sounds too much to me man
like that but the thing about the game
was
Yeah right the thing about the game was
that it was created so that you could
basically super moves and stuff like
that everything was kind of consolidated
to one button so all these crazy
combinations were kind of taken out of
the picture and you could focus on the
actual fighting and learning how to
implement these these moves during a
game and then you can you can piecemeal
it out afterwards if you want it if you
kind of wanted to make it more DIF
difficult for yourself and actually the
game the company that was making that
game got taken over by Riot the guys who
make League of Legends and they canceled
the game so that but from what I saw
early on it looked it seemed like
something that would sort of be able to
get people want into fighters now change
the fighters and explain those systems
make them a little easier but we got to
do it I get take take Lord addict into
the Tekken dojo far away from the Dragon
Ball Fighter Z I've actually been
watching a lot of videos on it it looks
really good at but actually the system
itself is actually seems very like it's
simple but it has a little bit of depth
I think it's only like three buttons and
less uh I was a big anime fan so I got
Rho into so caliber because of link
thank you so caliber okay hope for the
young wolf that was a minute and I tried
killer instinct when I first got my xbox
one I probably spent more time
downloading the game than I played it I
mean great great topic looking fighting
games on she knows near and dear to me
we've been playing them all the Lord's
we've been playing him for a long time
you know Tekken is my heart like I'm
similar to lord Erica you know Virtua
Fighter was the one that first captured
me graphically but when I saw Tekken in
just the true representation of martial
arts and ingest II you know that the
limbs The Right punch left punch left
kick and I remember seeing Tekken 2 and
seeing the counter system and Paul
Mina countered a move and I thought that
was amazing
like you know and each subsequent
version you know they added a character
that represented a different martial art
so when Tekken 3 came around and I saw
what on and I'm just like wow they
finally have a kicker like I found out
that nothing that gets back you know
back was the man and that was Lord Kings
guy no song ranked like the evolution of
kicking and I'm just like and I'm such a
fan boy for kicking so it was just like
wow this is truly amazing so you know
just to see that the title still strong
I can see Tekken sell successful at this
gate age I got a chance to meet Hirata's
Anand and III 2015 and he's such a great
guy and you know I told him I was like
you know you you have no idea how much
this game franchise means to us like we
we grew up with this thing and just to
see you guys support it and stuff like
that so and to Lord Kings point with the
storyline you know I think that's very
important what he said you know I like
to know about the character you know
their own personal struggles this Tekken
I was a little disappointed because um I
don't get me wrong the Machine masada is
great and it had to end and it had to
you had to get a combination on that but
I felt as a result the other character
suffered like if you play the game with
the other characters you don't get much
from a narrative perspective I want to
see them go back into that with the next
seconds and then on also after that like
as far as the microtransactions and
stuff like that you know Tekken Tag had
like a lot of suit so a lot of items
Lord Eric if you remember like there's a
lot of customization and I don't know it
just feels like taking something's a
little less on that you know so I'm a
little disappointed it's sort of they've
sort of what would you say they made
everybody sort of the same yeah yeah
like but Tekken 6 and those guys like
they each they had individual customized
acts items that really reflected the
character's personality more I thought
and you know I think too because I think
that that's such a huge that's such a
huge element now with every game the
ability to personalize your character
because yes
playing online and the ability you make
your own kind of character sacks
your avatar you want to make yourself
that's why the WWE game please go well
in yes you can make I'm gonna have a
friend who started at some people with
me he makes all of us every single time
and you know anything the amount of
customization that you can do in that
WWE game is incredible if you crazy
they'll do that with you know Tekken or
of Tekken just outdoors that technology
to someone else
mm-hm important asset creation set in
the Tekken that would have been really
all amazing
absolutely and like I said me it just
I'm just glad as much as I'm nitpicking
with sorry stuff I am glad to the genre
still alive and kicking
it's great to see street fighter around
it's great to see injustice all these
games you know III think there was a
period when the fighting game genre went
away a little bit and it to meet
refreshing to see it come back in people
still supporting you got my guy you know
large a bar he's in the chat you know he
does competitive tournaments all the
time I try to catch his stuff it's great
to see I actually catch coming to some
of the evils you know when I see those
guys fighting you know there'll be
obviously they're not athletes but you
know at the same time it's really
competitive its high level play nice if
they realize like yeah much as I think
I'm great
two loci leaders house thinking we were
like four from Lordaeron I got a chest
right now I will say this in my head I
put it this way let Eric I used to do we
used to do like the Bruce Lee stuff like
people used to come up tap their tap
your doorstep and challenge you to go to
hell I had people come down I mean they
heard like my Harang was good and we
would go to the arcade I'd never forget
like how it sounds these guys ignored
hard-nosed like I was one but [ __ ] fed
[ __ ] like I had it David don't speak for
a while
I did play it was played all walked into
your world and gave you a film no listen
that's my you going challenge in Lord
Eric and you get it you get some matches
in lily flow'r valuable so we got to
speak through a little bit so Lord
addict we know uh
cuphead released so we want to get your
in your impressions and bring that to
the round table the game is crazy
I love it I can't stop playing it isn't
sad that I sped home because I knew that
game was at my house all the time of
taken is like uncle kill that clown like
that clown is past this street and I had
people in my some people that made my
stream yesterday they were literally
starting to care how many times I was
dying I was like and then when I killed
the clown over Jason
what's that death count you can't go in
here again you know though so overall
very pleased very pleased with company I
would say right now
is definitely you know one of the
biggest cons and I know that this
shouldn't be a con is like I feel like I
like that I rip them off like the game
was worth more than I paid for cuz only
$20 me it's only $20 that's a good point
so not Lord Lord Eric now that you've
been hearing about this cop had gained
I'm talking about
will it be something that would be
interested interest you're about to
check it out I think because I love the
old school yeah and it's also has also
its co-op it's like a contra meets Mega
Man game has a lot of references to
gunstar heroes so much harder gunstar
heroes I would actually say it has it's
like this man that's like by streams
that has clips on Twitter right now
where he finally beat a boss and he took
a giant gulp of coffee too fast because
he beat this boss and he's so excited
the man nearly choked on camera
the little blob thing that jumps up he
yanked up so fast and he literally
ripped out the phone call the the his
headset cord that was in his mic you
could tell the thing like it had
resistance and it blew off of his head
yeah then he had one time where he lost
so many times he's around so hard but
like you said the difficulty level of
cuphead is definitely one of its you
know strong points this is a part of
part of the part of the job real quick
let's speed through um for me like I
said I get a chance to play it last
night for the first time
art-style absolutely amazing feels like
an old style cartoon they even have the
grainy film work over it is I mean
literally when I played the game
Lord Eric I just smile
all the way through like you just it's
just a feel-good kind of game you know
and you can't really help but to laugh
at this game because when you fight in
the clown this clown is if feels like
this clown is is mocking you the whole
time you're fighting but then you're
like okay it's not mocking me it's just
an idiot it's in the classic sound
tracks you know like the mean everything
oh it's just really good man it really
takes you and puts you in an area and
I'm just happy to see that they don't
like guys like Lord addict you know the
young generation and the way it's being
promoted it's a twenty dollar game and
just to see how much people gravitate
towards this it's really cool to see in
the community so that's all I got on it
imma let the rest of lords chime in for
I think for me is just the fact that
when I was younger I didn't play these
games as much because I sucked at them
it I didn't have I didn't have the
patience for like look I bought to a
tell you look I might this is his thing
like he gets into his own and he's like
a savant for this sort of stuff like
like you're indicating like what he said
cuz he beat the game already that's just
not something I would ever I would get a
few bosses in a few levels in and that
would be it for me but now like I'm just
I don't know I'm just more willing to
play anything and it doesn't bother me
I'll die 30 times and I'll just keep
going mad ago the fact like I said
before like this game is difficult but
it's fair if you die it's your fault
it's not really in any way shape or form
um the art style the the smoothness of
which it moves like I just got my own I
leave controller and like playing that
uh nearly control the d-pad like it's
absolutely fantastic
lenka so it has got that fallout music
though it's funny cuz loners have what
does destroy so just what you'd see if
you did good deal is a classic I'm just
glad that it's not one of those games
that was overhyped
when it first got seen and
announced and then didn't live up to it
I think it completely lives up to it on
the only thing I had so far that I don't
like so much is that I don't think the
the the running gun sort of platforming
stuff is super great I prefer the boss
Russ stuff it's good but it's not it's
not great to me but beyond that like the
game is fantastic and for 20 bucks like
really like there's no reason any you
know if you have access to this on a PC
on an Xbox
pick it up absolutely Lord King so your
your Twitter feed with the picture of it
oh I saw that with companies yeah when I
spoke to the devs at e3 and I got a
chance to speak to one of the main
cartoonists um and his the passion that
he had no cuz he was like close to tears
when he was handing out the buttons and
stuff like that and going into how long
it was taken for the game and with the
crowd still be around when the game
actually dropped because remember the
game was announced a while ago and we
all were anticipating this game coming
out and the realization that it was
downloaded into my system I looked and I
was like man I'm going to work right now
but when I come home I'm gonna tuck in
my eyes I'm like half I cracked and I
know it's real in my house you know the
game definitely lost a lot of its height
but it's one of those things were like
sometimes that fire is too hot that you
can't just shut the door launch it was
like it don't matter if you said that
game I don't I don't care about the game
anymore they turned around real quick
shut up the Lord Chris Colfer and Chief
Tom eated said he just thought about the
difficulty level they feel Dark Souls is
easier where I was on that it was the
clown off you stuck on that client for
like three hours man why you've gotta
see this clown clown where you jump
around a clown on a rollercoaster kind
of like amusement park thing
it's whatever but I was at the very end
and I saved my super I hit him for
two rotations and I was so confident I
was he was about to get this L I jumped
down to his platform did the super and
then I got killed and I was an
emotionally destroyed I just rolled just
happened this dude is a heavy
multitasker like you have to fight the
boss while also well what happened
roller coaster that's coming back to my
experience with the game play to have
cracked eyes and then I said let me get
back to it and when I was loading it up
all my kids was excited that I had the
game I didn't know that it affected them
because I showed them you know the
footage of it at e3 and I showed them
you know the YouTube streams of the of
the game before it was coming out and
that was a while ago and then I actually
got the game and all my kids sat down
and watched me play my son was so eager
to actually touch so we did couch co-op
and it's insane that it reaches back to
that genre and it can resonate with my
son and it could resonate with me and I
think this is the turning point and Xbox
exclusives I think this actually this
game actually if marketed correctly can
push them a little bit further because
you can't get this experience anywhere
else but in one spot and as then it's a
windows play anywhere so I just
downloaded it to my piece on right now
you know we don't count those guys um
cuz you know Phil is trying to build a
bridge and I actually think he's gonna
get that [ __ ] that bridge built um but
this this is it this is it guys and if
if at least 90% of the people purchased
this game it will validate these guys
hard work because I have not heard
anybody say anything other than it's a
little hard okay that's how games are so
yeah my experience with the game it was
fantastic it is fantastic and I will try
to be like Lorca bot soon and finish
this game because he's a
kabaah zoo powers you know he sits now
and like Lord sovereign said he gets in
his own and for him to finish cuphead in
a date Robin I challenge to mess with
that resume yeah you guys can check the
treatment it's on there yeah we believe
you look at let's uh wrap this topic up
I know we're getting a little over on
time and then the Lord everything's good
things he's got to do an also football
approaches so we got two topics left I
want to convince it to one so on for now
unfortunately not probably gonna do the
Destiny tune faction rallies um I just
want to say real quick that my thing on
it was just that it was fun you know
everyone picking this little ideology
and in destiny I thought it was
hilarious you know the future walk all
the free Wi-Fi new monarchy all I really
thought a lot of people who pick new
mark and have their like pretty much I
just thought it was a fun thing destiny
did it was really cool and we'll
definitely get more into that later but
since this is the last time we'll
condense this to one more topic which is
the G situation this this is still not
going away so lord service will be our
last topic pub G what's going on
fortnight what's going on talk to me
well okay the saga continues with a
fortnight and Blue Hole and pub G and
now has finally officially sort of been
confirmed that Blue Hole is in talks
with Sony and PlayStation to bring pub G
to the PlayStation platform this is
something that we assumed was gonna
happen anyway
at some point but the way Microsoft
spoke about how pub she was going to
come to their platform first it was it
was coming to early access on the Xbox
and the fact that they're publishing the
game on xbox and in some of the language
also indicated they were just publishing
on consoles period which wouldn't have
made any sense but it just the language
around it seemed like that
um so now it comes out that blue [ __ ]
has been in talks with Sony to bring it
to PlayStation platforms and the
shoutout to Lord Randall Randall Thor
who had some comments on this um a lot
of the thinking around that is dead we
don't know how fast it's gonna come to
PlayStation platforms it could be a year
it could be six months it could be a few
weeks afterwards we don't know when it's
actually coming to Xbox we're assuming
it's this year we're looking at maybe
December it's when people are thinking
that it will be ready to go on early
access but now the question the question
is how does this affect people's
perception of the game on xbox because
now when you have a basically
confirmation that it's coming to the
competing platform um I don't blame blue
hole for this at all because the fact of
the matter is that 60 you know 60 plus
million Playstations out there right
would make no sense not to put this in
business but Xbox fans maybe may feel
like well this was something that they
kind of held beer like okay this this
and cuphead are the things that we have
to look forward to as sort of
quote-unquote exclusives on our platform
this year and now the longevity of that
deal is brought into question and some
of the reasons behind this that people
are speculating about is the fact that
the issue with um with unreal and oh and
for tonight bringing this to the
forefront the fact that this issue with
for tonight bringing in a better world
mode basically kind of forcing blue
halls hand in to write a finishing the
Xbox version as fast as possible so they
can have pub G proper on Xbox consoles
as soon as possible and also bring a
version of pub to you the PlayStation 4
as soon as possible
to sort of stave off this sort of
resurgence in fortnight as a result of
them bringing this battle royal mode so
to sort of stave off the fact that you
know what they feel that
that epic did was for tonight and and
and sort of now repopulating more
popularity to their game based on the
battle royal mode because the game
proper before that wasn't about that at
all and really didn't have the
popularity that it seemed now with this
battle royal so the speculation is that
yeah they they're they want to bring
this to as many console gamers as
possible before fortnight takes off um
right yet and it's an interesting
subject I mean lord anchorman is a chat
right now he's basically saying that you
know they set this back and watch and
it's not new news which is which is it
is they did say that however the issue
that I think that law sovereign is
bringing which I also think is it's
pertinent is the fact that right now
fortnight is out there right forty
nights out there and they have a battle
royale mode which is kind of what pub
G's claim to fame is that's what made
pub key what it is it's this PC
sensation Lord Eric so to speak and um
you know right now they also work
closely with them you know when they
close we work closely with epic you know
on the engine so there's kind of
thinking that it's they've had the
inside track on pub G and then release
that kind of a battle royal mode in
their own day which the argument could
be made in which I'm hearing on Twitter
then these internet streets that
fortnight kind of looks like the more
polished better version of the battle
royal ball so I don't know that's not
fortnight that's pub jiva building there
you go you have a lot of people because
pub G's still not out yeah it's still
you know in revisions and stuff like
that you have a lot of people who are
looking at fortnight now like hey you
know why wait so I can understand where
pub she's kind of coming from you know
it's maybe some up some underhandedness
they're feeling away about it they
actually made a statement and action and
all this kind of stuff so this is
definitely interesting I want to get the
Lord's on it and hopefully more Lord
Eric to death too much if he's still
there um from an ethics standpoint
my name Loic I anybody was taught this
loader he's back yeah if you want like a
start so but basically I'm on what is it
I'm on pop G side with this as soon as I
heard about the fortnight better world
I'm looking at this like first of all
the pop G is made with Unreal Engine yes
who doesn't know no did they have to
talk about Unreal Engine to get the
kinks out and just to work with the
system they had to talk to epic which
means epic had to look into pub G's code
this is where note that hey the bird
that they had the thing it's like oh so
this is how this code that this is what
they were doing for this so because they
help and that isn't right to stow the
formula and again then they put here's
the hizzy an argument what was the
original story for tonight the original
story for fortnight is that you had
aliens coming in from a storm so it was
basically a horde mode and you bill and
you were and you doing building
fortifications and nobody's playing that
island real quickly on this one but the
real quickly I just want to get your
question all right
um have you heard of pub G in any
capacity Lord Eric have you okay the way
the synapses right now will play our
Nonis is it's dead it's the grace of the
internet right now it's basically what
is it would you say something like it's
the Hunger Games
anyway the movie battle royale so yes
basically people are down to what
actually understand why pub G is a crazy
so the premise of the game it's it's a
based off of an armored ARMA 3 mod or
armor 2 mod and basically what it does
is take the concept of battle royale
from like the movie or The Hunger Games
basically with a hundred people are
dropped out of an airplane onto an
island and it's basically the last
person standing wins and what they do
what they do is that you can is when you
drop down you don't have
and you have to sell you have to
scavenge weapons you have to scavenge
armor and it's very tense and what they
purposely do to make it even more tense
is that as people die they condense the
playable area that's this so it brings
you forcibly bring Boston closer
together so the map is like constricted
and and it gets closer and you if you
you have to stay within that zone like
as it goes on um and it just became
again released for like $30 in its
original state it's sold something north
of 13 million copies right now so the
fact that Xbox was able to secure it to
come first to the Xbox platform was it
was huge and the fact that's still
happening but the whole PlayStation 4
thing brings into question how long that
exclusivity is gonna exist and now this
thing with fortnight with the people who
provide the engine for pub G where they
are taking their game and added a battle
royale mode to it this essentially ID
and it is promoted in which the
developers from pub G felt away and they
would like it felt uncomfortable you
know because of that you don't so from
an epic standpoint you see where they're
going with it or do you feel like hey
all fair in love war this is gaming what
happens happens whoever has the better
game has to mitigate that the company
that used an engine they made a game
engine made a game that what kind of
sword against yeah yeah okay sorry my
phone's about to die here so we got to
let you go soon okay um yeah you know I
mean it sounds like your typical sort of
corporate corporate secrecy tricks
corporate spying tricks unfortunately
that's it seems like that's like the
name of the game when you're in I mean
you're in the corporate when you want to
play with the big boys like that that's
probably what happens I don't know if
there's any kind of like legality behind
it so it's hard for me to comment no
fair enough it
like I said if your phone drops and you
got a go week totally understand Lord I
got you for a while but um we just
finish this thing up real quick Lord
King Lord I'm addict and okay I mean
Christ went already but Lord King let's
get you in on this real quick you should
know if you got something popping and
the other guys is making a game at the
same time it's only human nature that
they're gonna look over and say hey and
let's use that now
this shady part comes in is the fact
that I'm the provider of this engine for
your game alright so what you drag your
feet gross get out in the preview
program get out of this breath and get
your game out so these guys is gonna get
their game out before you and then
you're gonna look like the copycat so
this might help Lord came out with this
whole segment that's gonna happen is
they're gonna be the actual game preview
and release the game preview quicker
they're not doing the full version quick
there you go thank you very much I think
I do want to say real quick before you
know Lori x-phone dies if it does died
we appreciate you coming on the the
podcast it was definitely a nice nice
addition you know I haven't been real
active this cuz you know the whole the
whole fighting genre and stuff is a
little above me I don't relate to it a
whole lot but I do appreciate you coming
on uh and when it comes to the whole
fortnight thing if I was pub G I would
be so furious it's not even like the
thing is it's like I don't even think
it's the fact that there's a copycat out
there I think it's the fact that someone
that they invited into they studio that
they license is like yo yeah it's it's
like it's like they they were helping
them and then they and they're sitting
that they were texting someone back home
like yo this is how they do this
because that's the thing happen anybody
else to come out before them with little
copycat then you understand but these
are the in-house guys and it's tube
routing like having like some of your
key developers leave and make a new one
epic that's what makes it worse they
paying royalties for an engine that the
AG provider Jake there I do it got it
out I deal stolen from there pretty much
3-wood and now as a result I mean here
now that you know I mean I think we here
now but we know that there may be more
incentive now for the devs a pub Jian
will hold to to get it out on ps4
multiple platforms and get it out as
soon as possible to kind of you know put
the finger in the dam before if if Fort
Knox phone so we're gonna wrap this
thing up yeah Brooke like I said thanks
a lot Eric for coming through man we
really appreciate you you know um just
can you get the fans and everybody they
know where they can find you and in
anything out in social media and stuff
like that yeah the Eric Jacobus was not
calm /d Harris and then easy to find on
youtube youtube.com slash dunno just
searching on YouTube easy to find and
then my twitter handle is yes I would
survive everyone if you want to see this
bare limits of what the human body can
compose and do [ __ ] do I think I'd have
to like kind of leg off to do that [ __ ]
some people got each other asking yes
not people is the YouTube channel please
he's checked it out or an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for coming to
spend as a time and we had a little over
yeah and we just love what you're doing
out they continue to
what you doing I'm gonna get ahold of
her out personally we're getting you in
tech and heat I don't care whatever you
say character the real official
character he's gonna be that character
that you click and it's like okay every
stock moved this dudes like choose his
face to be a new character with his face
this but he can get promoted in real
life okay would you alright let's do
these outros guys Lord automatic like we
can we find you you can find me on
youtube you know gay gaming addict I've
been streaming cuphead a little bit uh
for the most part it's been entertaining
people been really trolling me cuz
apparently I don't know how to platform
but it's it's it's whatever to be fair
their criticism of justified because I'm
telling you that clown dude had me gone
like gone gone but uh I beat him this
morning
you can find me on Twitter gave me as
you find me on a PlayStation and Xbox
room to kill I've been still trying to
change that to gaming at it but as we
can see PlayStation won't let you change
your gamertag and some dude that made it
an account six years ago that has like
30 gamers plans in the attic so we do
bars about that so I do appreciate all
you guys coming there like I said I
appreciate a Lord for coming through
again is definitely nice to have a you
know different perspective on the
podcast that just doesn't just do gaming
so yeah that's all cool
loss sovereign wicked once again thank
you we appreciate the insights man
absolutely lord King wicked if I'm
people find you well sort of Facebook
Instagram all the usual places
PlayStation Network its Xbox 360 lover
oh one add me not not fanboy trailing
you know yeah
Lord Eric it's been an honor having you
on today you truly don't understand how
much you have impacted us and it's
fantastic look like
has been after this interview for a
while and I'm both happy and proud that
he was able to secure it and you got on
and you're a great guy and it's
fantastic thank you so much for showing
up
yes sir hi Basu Channel Five's own wait
and find you well you can find me
looking around doing my thing on Twitter
at at lordcoyote2000 two words and I do
have a PlayStation Network account bx
kaiser although whether i use that
that's a different story or Jacobus i
prefer to usually be on the sidelines
like doing the chat with the guys with
the guys but i had to get onto this
clock house because the thing about
Jacobus i love is that he's bringing
keeping ted second alive with his videos
I just love that hat all the people who
listened to the iron Lord podcast this
is one of the pillars martial arts and
Tekken that's one of the pillars of why
we do channel 5 why we do the iron Lord
podcast so you want to know how our og
statuses it's because it is King brought
it out with mmhmm absolutely and of
course lockout needle here you know
spreading that game we're gonna Sony LP
telling you what you know what you want
to hear but what you need here again
thanks to Lord
Eric hope is for coming through absolute
pleasure to have this guy on and like I
said please hit that like and subscribe
to ILP and all the inner circle Network
media outlets including YouTube iTunes
Google Play of course the amazing tick G
and patreon is up it's been revised the
link is in the description please check
that out all the support really helps
the Lord in a much much appreciated
thanks again Lord Eric Jacobus and on
that note with an inner show okay